surprise I wanted to stop in check out
your office I understand we shot a
remote where I completely cleaned out
this office right do you think deep down
you want to be clean I'm open to it I'm
a little bit different not in the way
you're referring to what happened that
was a few years ago when new things came
in Wow
you've been with me for many many many
years yes yes throughout those years
I've asked you Jordan what do you do on
the show right and you always say with
all due respect it's not my
responsibility to tell you what I do if
you want to know what I do it is your
responsibility to research and determine
research why can't I just ask you the
circumstances which you perform have
dulled your senses and created a brain
which responds only to the macro not to
the micro I on the other hand deal with
the micro apparently so does your wife
[Applause]
that's a penis joke you have a fairly
large office okay and I suspect you do
nothing
I think it's possible you could do
nothing in half the space look I don't
follow your logic if you do nothing you
could do nothing in zero space I want
you to still be alive when this is over
at the dream zero space which has been a
fantasy
it would mean crushing you atomizing me
right putting you in a garbage truck and
having watching it be crushed and you're
talking but then eventually the talking
just starts to get quieter then it's
just a muffled sound and then the
crunching of the bones but you may
notice there and then a liquid seeps out
of the bottom and drop now I think you
can do nothing in half the space and so
what I'm going to do is cut your office
in half okay
George does your ass need to be so close
to my face during this process was that
part of the requirement you don't need
to bring it any closer
hey Jordan yeah it's amazing how much
free space there is over here it's
incredible
hey Jordan yes it's Conan okay
can I come in sure yeah
nice office Hey as a sort of a gift I'm
putting a putting a microwave in for
your office inmate next door okay this
is gonna go in this is uh for fish and
broccoli only Diane Harmon Diane what's
your title at the show closed production
you've done a lot of great stuff a lot
of great work on the show the travel
shows I thought you should have your own
office
I guess Jordan it's Conan okay
can we come in I guess no you good this
way let me get on this side hold on
oh you hungry at all should you like
some lunch okay okay do how do you feel
about fish and broccoli I give it three
minutes
I want you pretty much constantly
cooking fish and broccoli in this
microwave okay sure I feel bad that you
lost your window okay you would like
some natural light wouldn't you
I do appreciate an airflow and and
sunlight sure
that's a simple yes I'm gonna solve that
problem right now would you put these on
please
[Music]
I like things to look nice don't let it
be said I don't do everything to achieve
maximum efficiency here at the Conan
show I took one office turned it into
two offices I guess you could say I'm
the best guy ever and I am just saying
yes yeah yeah what about You Jordan I
would not say that
then I smell fish-smell feet were you
talking about it's not like jasmine to
me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]